breathing's from podcast Ville the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by and would love to
welcome squarespace.com listen let me
tell you something if you're looking to
turn your cool idea into a new website
or showcase your work or blog or publish
content or sell products and services of
all kinds or promote your physical or
online business Squarespace is for you
this is what I'm gonna do for you go to
head to whatever you want to do
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code Church to save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com enter code Church I'm
telling you beautiful templates created
by world-class designers powerfully
commerce commerce functionality lets you
sell anything online and the ability to
customize the look and the feel settings
products and more with just a few clicks
go to squarespace.com and enter code
church to get 10% off your first
purchase also to my main
brothers-in-arms or breathe down an on
it
pushing the [__] best fighters [__]
on the market we started off with alpha
brain we kick it off with shroom tech
sport and shroom tech immune it's [__]
and flu season and you're injecting the
flu and then you're coughing in my
[__] face after we sum up the joint
if you stick with shroom tech [__]
immune you won't have these [__]
problems Jordana combine now press in
charge man and get 10% off your first
order take this mother [__] meal Lisa
ass that's as good as it [__] gets no
man you know I'm first off welcome
[__] it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive it's
Monday you're alive you're kickin the
holidays are officially done it's the
[__] 8th it's my daughter's birthday
she's 5 I'm gonna have to go home and
get a Carvel cake from that time away
and at Weight Watchers ha ha
where'd you get her like Barbies or
something
[__] what is this Joey what is this nice
they did that Barbies that wife had to
take Harry to the cat fried haar to the
vet they did testing for cancer so the
vet appointment was five o'clock on
Wilshire Boulevard ah so I had a meeting
and I flew from the meeting to pick up
mercy and I took it each you wanted to
go to Boston Market she calls it the mac
and cheese joint from there I said what
do you want to do she was I don't know I
suppose let's go to Toys R Us it's your
birthday yeah we walked around there
eight times looking for hello well dolls
that's a little hot [__] thing yeah
they bang you the [__] out those little
[__] and then uh we went to a
donut place and I got a red donut yeah
my wife got home like at 9:30 you know
and she went out with the she came home
dropped the cat off and then her and
Mercy's teacher went out [__] ribs
where they got first grade next year
yeah next September Wow it's it's really
a ma'aming you know how fast time goes
by oh my god it's crazy but five [__]
years just flew by so yeah but that's
good that that's basically what's going
on with you brother oh man I just I was
home today and I had that epiphany of
like I need to move by The Comedy Store
this year
that's my girl so I want to just be able
to walk for now on like I do in New York
just walk everywhere I don't want to
[__] around in cars anymore I got the
same place as every night store improv
Laugh Factory
it's a triangle for me you know this is
that triangle store Laugh Factory improv
I can just get in the middle of that
triangle and walk everywhere so I was
like I got to do that that's what I'm
gonna do this year you know it's like
something I've thought of when I first
moved here was like like the first place
I had was like eight hundred dollars was
a it was actually like around the corner
from where you used to live yeah but it
like if you're gonna be here and gonna
spend so much time at your house might
as well enjoy it might as well enjoy
where it is yeah exactly
like I got a fantastic place right now I
love it and most people go wow your
neighborhood is amazing everything
but I feel like I'm on the road always
in my neighborhood I don't know anybody
like you know I walk I go to the
Starbucks I go to the gym I don't know
anyone maybe Steve Simone that's it you
know I feel like it's just like this
stranger out there for two years now
we're in Hollywood I go somewhere I run
into like five six different people I
know I get a podcast guess from it oh
and then I got a hey you want to do a
show tomorrow night then I get a spot
you know what I mean and it's kind of
crazy and electric jars my mind for
writing and stuff out here I'm just like
it's soccer moms and and bad Kardashian
wannabe ya know
oh here's the deal it's it's you have to
live like when I got here like anybody
helps I was in it to win it
yeah holla me so I was in Hollywood I
didn't want I didn't know nothing else
we were talking about for three months I
moved to Redondo Beach beautiful yeah
great phenomenal yeah when you're gonna
drive into Hollywood every [__] day
for this year yourself it sucks ass you
know so you get home at 6:00 you just
sat in traffic for an hour and a half
now you get time to take a shower you
know watch TV for a while and get back
on the car and shoot to Hollywood for a
9:30 spot yeah well I didn't enjoy it at
all
I knew right that in there that
California is great but if I'm gonna
live here I got a little close to
Paramount it's true you want to be a
[__] star y'all live close to parama
you want a mind for gold you gotta be in
the river I stayed in the [__] in
Hollywood and what after I stopped doing
blow I realized that I was wasting a lot
of times yeah I was wasting time hanging
out with worthless comics that would
just you know talking [__] all day yeah
on a system that's all they did yeah and
then they would point that Mealing look
at me like I was the bad guy well you
work at the store you're part of it okay
you know whatever yeah and I got no time
for yeah I got no time for this negative
energy so when I got into the valley I
kind of enjoyed not seeing anybody
yeah I kinda I had already paid my dues
in Hollywood I don't have anything to
prove I've already lived here ten years
when I moved to the valley and it was
like I got to the point where sometimes
you don't want to be at Starbucks I get
you for 10 minutes somebody's on top the
other [__] show yeah I wanted about
two months ago I had an appointment down
there yeah I had two hours to kill i sat
down this [__] homeless dude I knew
who had a house three or four-year five
or six seven years ago yeah we lived
three doors down from each other they
took care of his father what the father
died now you can see he was just
homeless with a bicycle he just stated
[__] [__] you see some rock bottom
man yeah no no that place is if you want
to get depressed go to the coffee bean
on Fairfax yeah that's the pressure
central because there's either poses
there yeah or people who were looking to
[__] destroy your head I remember one
day talking to a lady and she was
telling me why I was bad to belong to
say oh man you know like just beating me
up verbally because I belong to a Screen
Actors Guild like that it's this liberal
[__] coffee bean but does health care
you shouldn't have the health care
everybody's writing a script yeah
everybody's casting a reality show it's
just [__] that's the only thing that
my age I couldn't deal with no more
right like excuse me oh my god I saw it
destroy the other I have this script I
want to give you and your eye and the
[__] yeah leave me the [__] alone all
right yep I'm over here talking to a
buddy about [__] the Mets and you
want to talk to me about your [__]
short film script sketch yeah just it's
just that's the thing so now it's like
you learn to have a friend he lives
maybe an hour from the Comedy Store it's
that time you're all the time and I
thought about his journey and what he
does is he returns
anybody's called I called him trot today
and he did that purposely because he
knew he was doing something that night
right so instead of wasting time in the
daytime he calls you back at night on
the hour drive yeah
I asked him did he enjoy and he said
that years ago he was up here way before
I got into comedy way before I moved to
the valley and he said at that hour let
him become a human being again
I can once he got into a certain his own
he became a comedian and once he got out
of that zone he was just a dad yeah yeah
until this day I don't know how he's not
this tall four nights a week but it's
it's some people use it to their
advantage
yep I like that also I like the idea
once I had Laurel Canyon I'm out of here
yeah and there's days I go into
Hollywood and as soon as I get the
Hollywood I get pissed off because I'm
reminded that I'm in Hollywood yeah it's
pretty [__] brutal like I just left
Laurel Canyon where I saw a good-looking
woman the hot dress and nice shoes and I
go to Hollywood and I see the same
identical woman with blue hair
I had a hold of the skirt and you know
Dan I always eat a bagel at that place
right across from that Fairfax coffee
bean oh I don't know I don't go to the
griddle nah I go that way and there's a
coffee there's a [__] place that
makes a turkey they put a turkey on a
bagel for me the real Turkey Wow that
turkey slices so I've been going there
for [__] years and I'm sitting in
that just ordered them went father give
me the bagel and I see a homeless girl
Lee that was so [__] hot yeah her
hair was all [__] up she was filthy
and leaves on her leaves but she was
[__] huh Wow and I sat there go that
chick is it homeless she has mental
illness yeah because she sucked 20
produces digs and didn't get one roll
and she ran out just ran away into the
woods yeah like when I got my bagel and
I watched her as she ran into the woods
behind Bank of America yeah
officer yeah we you said it correctly
yeah uh I hadn't been washed and [__]
handed ship one day as she was [__]
beautiful Wow impulse I'm not saying
like be homeless but like I don't know
sometimes if I have like a really bad
dad being a car be like I could just
leave right now
no file every day yeah what fun every
day I always think like I'll just go
back to you cemani be a mountain man
it'll be silent yeah man that's Rhys
born go back that was always a dream
with me yeah you know it's funny how I'm
a city guy and the whole thing but
looking back I couldn't wait to move the
[__] cabinet yeah you know and at
that time I you know I was a Charles
Bronson dude so I want to live alone
with a dog yeah a couple shotguns some
weapons I hunted yeah ninja stars in the
stars
[__] this is a movie that called
death hunt that when I saw that movie it
just pushed me over the top yeah like I
thought like you know death hunt that
[__] me up and I mean death wish and
mechanic what you know death hunt is him
big he saves a dog in the Canadian
border and he saved me takes him home to
a log cabin wood fires and [__] yeah
yeah and as the owner of the dog was
back and he shoots him ah now there's a
war over the [__] dog oh my god it's
about a [__] dog if he shoots him in
the gullet kid that the Mountie is Lee
RvR Lee Marvin uh-huh Lee Marvin oh yeah
we Marlon has a scene between them -
that's brilliant
it's [__] brilliant comes through the
door he tells draws bronzy gotta take
him away and [__] yeah but once I saw
that movie I was like that's who I want
to be yeah I was 21 when I saw that
movie I'm like perfect
yeah there is a guy like that somewhere
magically you think like you're like wow
does that guy have money how did he do
that you know they're like you're just
living in the woods you don't need money
anymore if you live in the woods
well you gotta own that word log cabin
or something yeah not really
yeah I know right it's gotta be
something that well yeah I always have
that fantasy
you know like I'd go out there to the
desert and see the Queens of the Stone
Age guys or the Eagles of Death Metal
guys you know they out there Joshua Tree
you know and I get out there and I'll be
there and I'm just like you know you get
an Airstream for sixty thousand you set
it down out there and you just call it a
day you know off the grid you know to
mean like that's like Joshua Tree off
the grid desert living mushrooms [__]
around with your dog maybe two dogs me a
couple French bulldogs you know some
records that's it the same outfit you're
in same clothes every day who gives a
[__] you know have you ever said like
I've done a lot of driving in California
the last few months yeah and there's
people who take those those trailers and
they don't even go to like a nice area
they're just like it seems like they
find a cliff in the desert or just a
space in the desert that's [__] and they
just put it down yeah like we're here
now Venice Beach you go out there every
side street has these trailers these
motorhomes like [__] Rockford Files
style every one of them like the ones ad
and braking bag they're making the
methane don't be able to lived in one
now have you ever lived in wife's taken
one let me tell you sir yeah I lived in
one yeah and I moved from Seattle
Washington to Los Angeles or one and
actually lived on Fairfax for three or
four streets and then after that we
moved to the school off of Fairfax again
yeah by the pizza place and Cantor's
there's a school there oh yeah yeah and
we lived on that block by the bomb we
would watch the kids [__] practice
soccer yeah just in a Motorhome yeah
yeah but I lived in that motor home for
probably from October to January ah and
we and it was interesting because you
had to fill up the water you could take
a shower but it's not the [__] shower
night so you know that's a bottle over
yeah like a monkey it's like a [__]
ship yeah it's a little shower the water
there's no water pressure know the thing
you could see if you don't fill it up a
water it starts to thin out
shampooing your hair no idea
the pump that's all fun and dance yeah
well but again you're cooking then the
bet is run across the [__] Street the
bet is ten feet do not even the bet is
to free from the [__] stove you know
yeah all day can you know we had a we
had what's that the generator can you
have the AC on all day generate right
the [__] meter Jesus we had a cable
TV what did you own it but Kay she owned
it oh yeah yeah but then when we lived
in Seattle she found a place where you
just pull up your tank like an RV home
nicely and I got to tell you something
if things ever got if some man between
me and my wife and I got old yeah that's
how I would live I dig it that's what he
said they got the hookups out there now
they got this was 1997 and the place was
50 years old I can't imagine what new
places all these homeless people so
basically you pull your RV and late what
you plug their electricity your
neighbors all have our bees yeah and
there's a compound and the compound
there's a gym there's a swimming pool
heater there's a sauna there's a
washer/dryer there's two restaurants as
a post office there's a clothing store
they have everything you could imagine
have this place a shoe store you know
yep you're not gonna get great deals you
don't get Foot Locker deals you paying
ten bucks extra
now you're living in now have Murder
House but you live in the [__]
morning room they have a conference room
where you could go in to watch TV at
night um you sick of time this wasn't
bad I'm a pain in the ass to live with
and I gotta tell you something this was
not bad yeah I would like that like if
I'm gonna live in one of those I want to
be on the road though like if like I was
like it could go from state to state
like Park in those yeah
whenever you get there that's Sean Penn
you know when his house burned down out
in Malibu
he bought a an Airstream and set it down
and he had the you know that the place
had plumbing and everything so he just
hooked up the water and the electricity
he lived in that Airstream you can
Google photos of them
he looks happier than I ever seen him
ever he's got the door open he's like
yeah I live in this motorhome kind of
[__] you know
if you're a practical person yeah and
likely you like to drive and you know
you put a little grill in there I mean
listen man there's nothing like taking a
year off from your job you get fired one
thing you only wear this thing I'm gonna
give me unemployment I put away all this
money over the years you know I'm gonna
[__] rent an RV yeah perfect for me
and just go across the country all these
people always want to go with overseas
yeah [__] that I always tell people
you're crazy America is killer
listen the trip is an RV trip from coast
to coast yeah with with a 6-month limit
know that she'll look at six months that
you don't have to work you figure out
your gas mileage you know you got to get
a good ID because you know what [__]
[__] breaking on the road now it's a
nightmare
you know what les claypool I've just had
him on the podcast from Primus and Burr
and I were hanging with him in Austin
and he goes I've toured for 30 years I
didn't see one [__] thing in America
so he bought an 85 Prevost tour bus
about five years ago yes and he drives
the bus his own bus with his wife and
they drive from gig to Gig and he sees
America and he lives in the bus and he's
like this I'm seeing everywhere they
stop it instead of staying at hotels now
they stay it like you know and Utah like
weeping rocks or they go to you know
Boulder or the top of Vail or wherever
they can feel these cool campgrounds on
the tour so they see America it's pretty
rad
it takes a different type of person I
was watching that movie with that chick
that she you know she's a [__]
part-time hooker and a mother dies of
cancer Oh monster no the really
good-looking chick and the movies are
wild into the wire now while the Sun
shines [__] walks they saw they show
getting [__] and they show doing
heroin and she goes on a walk and during
the walk it's like I don't know the
track what the name of the movie is not
a bad movie but you why yeah Reese was
oh oh that one that's her
while you're watching the movie you're
thinking to yourself could I handle
something like this yeah
can I walk ten miles a day for a [__]
year nope
living camping shoes and [__] yeah
look outside and take showers outside
that's a [__] rough journey but that
is man there's a like I always say I
always say this and I I said it numerous
times to people I'm all my chips are in
on-on-on comedy it's all I do I love it
every day but if I wasn't in comedy I
would definitely be long gone in like
you know Toto Santos down on the you
know the bottom of the Baja down their
back side of Cabo or Joshua Tree or
beautiful Yosemite and just completely
disappear and just man I bet you live
another 20 years because of just zero
stress and decompressing no traffic no
noise you know what I mean a whole
different thing
like our whole life is noise and traffic
and everything but it it it gets your
brain going for comedy you know it's
pretty interesting yeah it's totally the
more and more like yeah I've lived here
I've tried to make my place comfortable
yeah but one of my goals is your things
I'm working on this year's getting out
of the house yeah yeah you don't want to
be comfortable at your Hut Netflix well
it's not even Netflix it's just I like
my bed I have a comfortable couch like I
can't tell you how many days I sit there
and I'm just on my phone or my computer
but I'm there without I don't turn the
TV on no I know but it's like you were
saying about Hollywood how you get you
just run into people even if it's not
people you know it's people who couldn't
connect you like if you're working or
something well you know it's human
contact right good you got a house the
contact is important that's like New
York and well New York OB walks and
looks the other [__] way you have your
little buddies at different stops
advance through the O's yeah like that
but that's what you need sometimes I
mean these days I talked to leave in the
morning and I don't talk
nobody for my one yeah yeah son
everybody wants to talk to you yeah I am
saying awesome 22 people want to talk to
so this days I'm sitting on my I'm gonna
have any contact with nobody might as
well go train so I can have contact my
people had human touch of contact yeah
very important also I mean I can't I
don't you yearn for certain things I
don't think a lot of people can handle
yeah like I always thought I can be put
on an island for a year by myself I
don't [__] think so I don't think say
oh thanks so at least put me on there
with a cat yeah yeah and I'll start
talking to the cat after three months
you will you put me on an island with
twenty pounds of weed and [__] music
and a cat yeah and a kettlebell with
something and [__] endless chicken
cutlets with mashed potatoes oh yeah
that's the lottery right there you just
won the lottery that was the original
dream guys yeah to just live [__]
callous and not need much money and
maybe have a make enough money just to
cover the spread
and that's it put away what what do you
gonna put away yeah I and you go now and
that's it yeah there's no big [__]
deal you know I keep trying to get rid
of everything at my house except for my
records and my clothes just everything
in there so it's just complete freedom
here and I mean like alright if I just
want to move tomorrow to New York or
something I got these items right here
I'm out of here
yeah man well that was part of the
reason I got into comedy in the
beginning is fit everything that was
going on with my life I got divorced I
wasn't going anywhere and the road just
did it for me where the SAS you go to
all these places and in those days you
weren't gonna go to Las Vegas I was
going to Riverton Wyoming yeah I was
going to Billings Montana shitty spots
that become amazing they're amazing yeah
and every time you get there you go [__]
I can live here yeah every time if you
haven't been to Montana you the Big Sky
oh my god it's [__] beautiful I have
my omen you know it's just one right now
Wyoming if you're freezing in New York
oh yeah you're a statue and well oh my
god I was you're a sir
not you and what there's no buildings or
anything so there's will here's wind
what about you Joey for the last few
years you would be in Minnesota this
week or the week before Buffalo - oh but
that's three days late yeah that's three
days yeah yeah you go outside to smoke a
joint you sit out there for as long as
you it's not a rat in it and you run
back into your [__] hotel oh oh yeah
I can't wait the end of that player
these fools live here and then you go to
the airport you took you put your
luggage you put your heavy Jack in your
luggage yeah but then you get the other
thing and they call you back on the
plane and as you walk through that tube
into the flight oh you're gonna like
you're [__] freezin the best is when
you come off the plane yeah walk into 30
below and you're like Jesus [__] you
that right Capcom Wow you're not used to
it at all
yeah like III listen I've been talking
to my friends on East Coast at least two
of them the last two days a buddy of
mine had a situation and we've been
talking he always tells me how bad the
[__] weather is how cold it is
so I grew up in it but it's gotta be I'm
glad I'm not there I know my god yeah
let's I love it there and I'm just like
well there are too cold memories that
stick out in my mind there's one January
night when I had a quaalude and we
partied inside the middle of a river
lake yeah we would call it the island of
insanity party the lake would freeze
that's one memorable night and I'm very
lucky not to have gotten like when your
fingers get we got frostbitten I passed
out and somebody's uh-oh were in a
building yeah in Jersey I woke up the
next one I can't believe I was [__]
alive and there was another night there
was a day that I was I was just getting
into comedy it's January of 95
yeah and I'm starting to make a little
contacts in Denver and my buddy Rick
Kern's got bless his soul system hey
mint what's his name they got he would
always give me work and pay my rent then
I would do the jobs yeah if I needed
rent money I would just ask him and that
he just booked me yeah yeah and so he
throws he's got a gig you're opening for
meanwhile
it's like 400 bucks for two showers it's
good money Tom you want to be on it you
know I'm like yeah let's do it was me
him and then comic named George McClure
something McClure yeah and we [__]
and went up there and Jesus Christ Lee
Jesus Christ oh yeah
first of all if it was like in a barn we
did comedy 500 people yeah slow down oh
yeah they got nothing to do on a Friday
oh they're home and fries yeah so they
all go to the community center and drink
beers for $8 for $5 a bottle and watch
comedy I bombed boat shows on Friday
night or hey I go back to the hotel the
guy offers me food to have like bad
banquet food yeah like spaghetti and
like different [__] my gonna I don't
want that [__] and I went back to the
hotel room it's more I got like I wasn't
bold I asked the hotel guy like as Danny
breakfast thing as my you missed
breakfast I go where can I go eat around
he goes I know danger and what do you
mean he goes it's down the block but you
ain't gonna make it 35 below oh my god
you don't be in those days yeah I'm like
I just did bloat await the morning I'm
number two this [__] onset me out
there dawg halfway out there you're
[__]
it's like when you do that thing from
Cuba to the United States
yeah in the middle you realize you can't
swim no more and you still see you gotta
make a decision yeah you gonna go
forward or go back that's how bad it was
yeah it has that type of [__] cold
you gotta go for it
get that foot man I remember that was
very very cold in my youth and with the
Sierras met New Year's Day yeah and the
car broke down the kid ice I was went
with his mother's car broke down at the
Nassau Coliseum ah fine we had to wait
for the [__] tow truck to come till
1:00 in the morning
ah and we [__] sat out there barely
in tears like we took everything out of
that car everything that was in that car
- and the car was worse than when it was
outside oh man
would have to go on yeah yeah that's
right the call was worse than what it
was outside yeah we just huddled
together we signed there was no
cellphones pure metal you know there was
no cell phones there was no nothing yeah
that's the worst back then yeah I think
of all the times I stranded with no harm
back there God no man's land
no cell phone in those days of you see a
[__] payphone
you were goddamn dead man I'll tell you
when I froze man a fierce freezing in LA
like two years into comedy I was doing
maybe three years I was doing the
Hollywood improv at like 8 o'clock 8:00
to 8:15 spot it's about 60 out and then
I had a headliner spot at 11:00 in
Bakersfield it's like a plenty of time
you know 60 out I start cooking going up
the grapevine or the motorcycle on the
motorcycle way back yeah I'm on the
motorcycle and I get about you know
halfway up and I go oh man it's kind of
cold up here I completely forget you
know then I'm going over the [__]
grapevine
so from 60 all said now it's 40 oh then
it's like 33 it starts snowing and I'm
like I gotta get to this gig I need this
[__] money and I'm freezing
my left thumb is numb I'm trying to hide
my hands behind got gloves on but my
thumb's are out in the open there you
know like this I'm trying to hide my
thumb and I'm trying to ride and it's
like it's snowing like sleet my hand is
completely froze and now I pull into a
truck stop I buy like a hot chocolate
and I just hold the Cho I'm not even
drinking it I'm just holding it to heat
my hand up high by some kids mittens put
those on then put my gloves back on go
to the bottom of the grapevine I get to
the gig there's like eight people there
they're watching the Raider game it's
just finishing up you know it's like a
Friday night Raider game and they go all
right you're going on now they got just
no one here they could just do a ten and
we'll pay yeah okay cool I do the 10 now
I gotta turn around and ride back over
the [__] grapevine and I'm still
frozen like to the bone
no run just like [__] got home I just
showered for like an hour I can't even
believe I made it home
and my hands were just torched man like
frozen my [__] feet my big toe
everything man on the bike it's not fun
I don't want to be in that weather right
now [__] now you know last week I I was
thinking about something I'm a YouTube
guy yeah me too so while I'm doing [__]
I got YouTube on and sometimes you put a
certain song on often this song comes on
three songs later that is a tremendous
song that you forgot completely about
yeah and there's some music that you
hear like we said you listen to me go
[__] I can't believe all this [__]
10 years ago I know years ago yeah some
[__] that you hear that it still holds
oh and you think of it like and when you
tell people listen I want your top 10
ounce right away they never throw the
why how about you Pink Floyd the wall
and [__] you know a rumor is buyers
lie by Fleetwood Mac those are
no-brainers doesn't the obvious I wanted
to call and talk to Dean about hounds
that were brilliant albums in their own
manner but also affecting you a certain
all right which nobody ever [__] talks
about I don't we don't want to talk
about that [__] yeah What's Your Number
10 out now you said you had a story
about this when I called you yeah but
it's a [__] [__] to pick that
out yeah oh yeah music lover oh yeah so
I'm gonna hit you with 50 different
genres yeah let me take art right now
I'm trying to put together this five
minutes for Conan to shoot to send it to
submit this is a hundred thousand times
harder putting together this [__]
unless and and the thing is there's all
these different things a list twenty
years ago would have been way easier
than a list right now cuz as you live a
long [__] time you know things slide
out you know and then there's genres
you're like well [__] man can we do it
in genre as you know because it's so
hard and I say
there and I was just like this is
impossible
absolutely and I think I could do it in
yeah it's 20 25 pounds yeah
but 10 is so [__] hard I was going
through all my [__] and what I did was I
put all the albums I was up to like 30
and then I would just slot some out and
and I would slide them out for reasons
like I love this record but it's an
absolutely desert island top ten is it
that you know and I mean it's it's weird
because you know in 2000 my top 10 would
be way different than 2017 you know I'm
saying but then don't you think also
there's a difference between top 10 and
like desert island because desert island
is stuff that you want to keep watching
maybe something on your top 10 is really
great but you don't want to listen to it
well top 10 to me it has to be it has to
be you know something you don't
it takes you on a journey so let's say
you have this type of record that's
number three it's the number four it's
got to be totally different you can't
have ten of the same [__] thing
you'll go crazy like if you're like I'm
into the Ramones and Dead Boys and you
know all punk rock or something you just
have to why you're like I'm a [__]
[__] them on this island but to me top
ten island records are the same as top
ten records come down because they're
gonna be on this island by herself and
they're gonna jar memories all right the
most brilliant albums I ever heard was
the best of bread right I didn't know
what the [__] bread was but if there was
five songs on one side four of them were
monsters yeah that was my first album
that I wasn't and said what the [__] is
this because I had born with the Beach
Boys and the other seven songs I like to
over yeah the other seven songs were
just pure cactus so that's another thing
in my top ten the record can't have any
filler tracks you know because there's
records that I [__] love look like
I'll tell you what I love the NWA
Straight Outta Compton right right but
to me it's a four song record it's a
four song record you know once
to the back half oh my care this is
pretty good we're public enemy
BlackPlanet is a master tumor all the
way through this price I forgot about
that that's a goddamn journey to Moscow
you know fear of a black man there was
another one yeah nation of uh it takes a
nation
how many islands they pull out all
together let's still put him on oh they
still put him out of work you know was
listen dollars first you know the nation
and fear of the black plan when I got
the prison the nation first one yeah
they were playing that's [__] great
and that was great that was the first
one then once fear of a black planet
Allah brilliant and that movie despite
great to do the right thing yeah it's
just as brilliant the dual it's a dual
punch in the face
well I can't because I don't have the
same relationship you guys do with music
but we just did a podcast with Ramos
about movies so I was I'm wondering joy
was it similar was it hard like this
similar it was it harder to do music or
oh was that I said that today the Steve
Simone at the gym I said movies is ways
here way [__] easier I could do the
ten why we're standing here why we're
standing here I could just name him off
the ten one top movies that's easy
but again everybody has a preference
because they were at a certain place in
time right when this movie came into
that I totally tell you might watch that
movie and call me no Joey really no
words were ever seen it just treated me
you know I like valley girl yeah for
some reason I love the movie valley
girls that my top ten no it's not well
it's a great [__] film mean
understand I'll always I always wondered
what happened to that girl then I saw
one man TV and I was happy yeah even
went back to look for a son [__] what
should number Ten's
album I mean yeah would it be fear of a
black planet
cuz I'll tell you what not he thought
about that fear of black planet is
definitely up there it's old
Maga and the other one would G thing
yeah
oh yeah [__] uh yeah the chronic dr.
sivana that's a four song album oh yeah
to me yeah yeah what do you think
I think the chronic is to me I think
it's a masterpiece of hip hop The
Chronicle yeah I really let me listen to
it again
yeah because I have a copy here you know
recent number the other side recently I
did that set in the main room at the
store and Dre was in the crowd and he
came out to the parking lot and he said
man you were [__] funny and it it was
one of the highlights in my life because
that record at the same time I was
listening to rock and roll I was
listening to that chronic record and
it's just the ultimate party wreck I
gotta hear I forgot that was even on my
list and think of that yeah I tell you
the first biggie ow oh I think is a
masterpiece yeah and it's old [__]
ghetto right and the second one has
different things that have always
[__] jolted me
he's so crazy that [__] was [__]
tremendous and NAS is out yeah the one
nas album [__] killed me you know and
again I've been smoking dope guys and
this has been 20 [__] years
yeah since I listened for this stuff I
mean I'm gonna [__] man me too I'm a
tailor what album [__] me up for a long
time get your wings by eros oh [__] yeah
I've always thought that's a brilliant
band album that was the best work and a
lot of people are you could be the line
I've always been partial to get your
wings there's like four [__] I like
an outlet flows yeah me too you know
Judas Priest
screaming for vengeance no no British
steel British steel unbelievable that is
a work of art yep they made that whole
album flow when you listen to a side
with [__] metal gods and you flip it
over and whatever you can't be cruel to
be kind
hahaha
you have to be old to be wise you're
sitting well this is [__] brilliant
yes there's some hounds you know if I
come to Judas Priest it's between hell
bent and British steel for yeah yeah
yeah after that I know Judas grief but I
got out to me it's the live record which
one really the priests live record man
really Oh Oh least to me no that's up
there oh oh you know that's the you know
to me it was these bands that the ones
their live albums hit me like Ted Nugent
double live gonzo ac/dc if you want
blood
you know the Frampton and the priest
they were the songs had it so much more
muscle so much more muscle they've just
come on you're like what the [__] like
the sinner on there
I came one night by myself in here we
was home I called and I went for a ride
must have been like I told my came in
here and I we just wanted to smoke a
bump
yes it I just want the smoke something
different was it off tonight and I put
on a double-wide gun oh my god
and it took me right back to being in
the [__] eighth grade yeah and
hearing it and at that time you know
when a lot of people understand in the
late seventies early eighties a lot of
bands were putting on live out yeah that
were [__] phenomenal unbelievable you
know phenomenal from [__] kiss alive
yeah DNA that list goes on if you look
at the live catalogue that everybody had
at least one live album there's no more
live music Cheap Trick Budokan that's
right
smoking you know what I can't [__]
stand them oh yeah I like the album
heaven tonight oh great yeah heaven
tonight was right on my cheap trick I
mean yeah maybe I just have a terrible
taste in music who knows but when I when
I was growing up I would always avoid
and this even on YouTube we avoid live
recordings because it just doesn't
always sound as great as studio I know
that's it's adjusted but these were
different there they were paid for
high-dollar live records done with a
mobile truck 24 track they're not just a
couple guys with mics in the room
you put it on it's [__] sonically a
masterpiece also so they're just too
expensive to produce is that why did
they stop doing it now they still do
them but they don't sell like back then
it was a thing - you're like hey man
you're you're eating dicks you're not
selling anything got to put out a live
record and they put a live record out
everybody started doing it once like
Nugent and cheap trick and it was really
that Peter Frampton Comes Alive when
Johnny Cash through his live album at
the Folsom City prison or that one that
thinks great that's what started it
it's [__] smokin because even he had a
fight - record label to get to live on
they kept saying oh you know you didn't
want him to do it there yeah I've always
thought if you do live out and had to
have a catch but I'll tell you what
happened to me yeah
one of the first live albums I bought
was Giggy Yaya's out ah great in my
world yeah it wasn't great right my
world it's pretty dirty and nasty yes
yeah I just sounds like a garbage can
some reason at that age a did not
comprehend what they had done to the
songs yeah yeah and why they had done
that to the songs right exactly it is
always different and then I was turned
on to this for me is the same yeah which
they tended to do the same exact thing
take the [__] song to left field I
couldn't criticize Led Zeppelin for
years yes it didn't talk about it yeah
yeah I just didn't talk about it when
people brought up but because of those
two albums yeah I got turned off to live
music gotcha and then my brother Steve
Ronnie in detention or in study hall
gave me the cassette to unleased at
least and I put it on and changed my
perception that I still remember Ted
Nugent them new young pal the guy that
was just it was just wrong and I still
remember that summer with [__]
Frampton I also remember the summer with
meatloaf that's not a pleasant
yeah
they're a meal of God we never never got
in there nothing like that see in Iraq
you go with you now I liked it with
Queen but I just was I was never into
that a queen Night at the Opera oh man
there's death on two legs on that I
don't know check that out real quick so
learn at the Opera tonight is a Opera
Queen what songs around there def on two
legs is on there that's a really really
good out those rounds that were quality
yeah it was kiss studio albums when I
was a kid no yeah it was also solid rock
and roll was alive I liked well I was
thinking so live kiss alive - was me
because I was you know a couple years
behind and I got the kiss alive - with
the tour book and the tattoos you know
if you wet them down and you could have
the tattoos on your arm
what do you got alright so sad one is
death on two legs
yeah that's the one yeah yeah that's a
masterpiece now yeah yeah and that's the
world with a Bohemian Rhapsody correct
not the Opera yeah I know that's done at
least sad to number 11 Bohemian Rhapsody
okay yeah so it's none of that
okay I'm sorry that you're talking about
the track so number two is lazing on a
Sunday afternoon I'm in love with my car
you're my best friend
yeah 39 that's the out dog sweetly yeah
and it ends with seaside rendezvous and
then it goes to the Prophet song love of
my life good company Bohemian Rhapsody
and god save the queen yeah that damn
hit it out of the park from me with
Queen I got my number eight here or
number nine I mean what do you mean
overnight Achtung Baby
you too now let me tell you something
about this record you too when they came
out all the you know clove smoke and
goth you know people were into the
coffee shop you know like oh here comes
Dean the rocker where do you - you know
and it's like yeah that like you two -
he'd [__] dicks yeah and I mean but I
wasn't like a freak
matter of fact they tell this story all
the time my buddy mark Baker
played in the spam liquid sky and he'd
loved you too and I told him to get the
guns and roses ep
you know and I was at a party guys here
you can have this these guys suck
they're going nowhere and he gave me the
EP on cassette you know I was like all
right you'll see it they became the
biggest band ever but in the meanwhile I
bought Achtung Baby I remember and I got
home and I go this records garbage and I
went back and I returned it what you
can't do you know the man I said hey
yeah this thing it sounds horrible on my
system and I don't know what's going on
I got my money back and I was like whoo
thank God you know and then I saw you -
about a month later on that tour I took
some mushrooms I was at the Oakland
Coliseum they had the mini coopers
flying around they come out he comes out
as the fly Bono and it was religious and
I [__] fell in love with that record
I went back and bought it the next day
and I played it like every week my whole
life and it's it's a masterpiece to me
it's a journey just like that fear of
the black planet it's a [__] smoker
man
the u2 album that cut that cut it for me
was the one in 87 that they did a tour
on now yeah
oh yeah but my original love is war war
that with refugee and all that yeah
that's 85 yeah living in a hotel room
and a tenderloin yeah in San Francisco
Robyn yeah and all we had was that
little cassette deck me and the girl
well he had war we had belly oh don't
even have belly we had a boy oh my god
no no no no oh my god oh my god I just
from time to time they come into my mind
yeah we had those two hour we were like
fugitives I was a fugitive yeah living
in a little [__] man Ginny and hotel
which is now or whatever you two
fugitive rockin war was my hair
after that has shot day ahaha first two
shot day album shared are up there my
world i swatted it in there came out it
came in and out of my list today in and
out cat we're coming out what's the one
diamond life diamond one yeah I saw her
on one of those tour 85 I think I saw 86
dude I saw her live
I still cannot [__] get it whenever I
see Tony Baker who we both love her
still now and my that we're forgetting
the part of the memories you know as far
as like why something hits you so hard
that was a fantastic girlfriend that I
had at the time for like seven years and
she loves Charlotte and and I got turned
on to it and then we went and saw and
whenever I think about when I hear it it
takes me back to that that relationship
you know and that relationship is was
just gone because I was playing rocking
Bronski beat what Bronski beat what's
that you remember Bronski beat no
Bronski beat b ro and s ki ba ta put
about two hours that's the name of the
band yeah well I got it was ex members
from something when I got the boulder
yeah
this was doubt that's some of that the
people at pogos and all those places
listened to yeah yeah this was the end
outlet [__] right here what's the hit
song uh [__] down there that's it on
let's go with the small town boy you
know things got twenty seven million
views holy smokes
this was the first of this music right
and then it blew up and these guys were
the [__]
this is what the girl I was baby inside
there's that drum machine all the band's
sound like this back then this is a
teapot yeah is this program bass and
drum into a guy's jumping up and down up
at a budget for a video video right
white wines by Duran Duran I played this
last time somebody was listening to what
the [__] is that
yeah I saw them to do it one night late
like I let him in and I blew my mind I
always need to rant Iran had [__]
balls
[__] great white lines rockin this is
tremendous yeah nobody remembers this
[__] oh yeah this is [__] awesome
here we go hella get him just whip the
line up below her over his nose there we
go
it's great muscle this is [__]
surrenders well good
do that
it looked great
[Applause]
what's the singer's name in Simon Lebon
[Music]
this is about great
[Applause]
[Music]
it
we'll hit the [__] head to the Simon
that a bomb is that's your next egg yeah
that's before Oh aces [__]
[Music]
so Judd
you know there were some bands that you
look at and you go wow
my girlfriend life some more my gay
cousin likes him or whatever and you
look at the men of the bands kind of it
when I saw that I always knew there was
something to them oh yeah like I stroma
being 21 in Colorado and they had just
gotten band yeah if something happened
like already then they were Provo
there's a song they did and they [__]
cut like a video yeah shakes [__] in
the TV plays out of my hey yeah that's
what somebody could drop it up and go
put it on don't worry button yeah yeah
yeah we're good yeah yeah yeah also the
chicks tip would be fine yeah so did a
video come into consideration tonight
this is like a really awesome video
making an album that much better
no [__] yeah the eighties the video I
listen you would stay in to watch world
premieres yeah I still remember thriller
primary oh yeah absolutely I can't
imagine you know there was no internet
counts nobody was watching I know you
half the [__] world
nobody was really watching and Michael
Jackson did it perfectly in those days
he dropped a single on you in September
like a [__] up kind of single there
they dropped one on you to make it dance
yeah he took over his plant like what's
going well yeah they were talking about
this Lee and I about plans there's no
more planning and show business unless
you show up with a very big envelope and
even then the planning is weak ie the
guy for Sons of Anarchy yeah they took
that guy to be a movie star
ain't gonna happen he came out with
three bombs yeah crazy yeah this is a
guy that made 750 an episode on cable TV
he could sink the ship on network TV if
he wants to
I told my agent listen telling ya this
[__] movies are uh frakkin this mm
coming out every week nap to rough
racket guy stay in TV and build a movie
career up Toby selectively that's what
you tell your people not anymore with
Michael Jackson he did it very
strategically he like release the song
and then he waited till the [__]
Motown 25th anniversary and he destroyed
America his real owner walks a just
moonwalked him and leveled them huh and
then from there he just started dropping
bombs on your mom's then the Thriller
video came out by that time I had 20
little kids up at the farm and nobody
was gonna see him for three weeks you
know I'm saying ranch it is [__]
crazy
and even though sounds like you look
like it city new year throws only great
sounds of all time we all know that and
drill is a great album for me yeah
brings back a lot of memories but not
enough off the wall to me is better one
one video that always destroyed me yeah
and guys like I said Wednesday nights
for me in the 80s was dynasty oh okay
dynasty was what you did with a chick
you on a bang yeah
you stayed at home with her on Wednesday
night you stopped a little spit but
you're always visit on there because she
having it for work the next morning
yeah so you let surgeon you left him met
your friends at 10:30 and still snorted
coke till 3:00 in the morning and nobody
knows nothing that a plan they didn't
know your snag on the cat's going I love
dynasty baby they think you're going
home
no you want to meet the [__] gorillas
yeah I do method of method I do holy
rock and roll
that's a they call you an eight how was
your night oh my god yeah I was with
[__] beer on up and [__] I got a
weird flavor in my mouth that's what you
young yeah I appreciate you doing yeah
it's said sure and I used to just once a
week I would watch Seinfeld with my girl
you know we have like that TV night we'd
watch some side
and she would make me mac and cheese and
steak
you're not taking mac and cheese the
Velveeta shells one with the cheese and
the gooey cheese in the bag
that's disgusting yeah it was like
that's the high taste yeah that's part
of it that's probably a rule all she
needs is dirty feeding you there at
night you know tapioca protein ain't no
it's just on MTV was doing premieres and
this particular Wednesday night I don't
know what his girls happened the big
decision was we're gonna watch the
premiere of this video or [__] watch
dynasty ocean dynasty was getting deep
yeah thanks Dexter was getting with the
[__] Queens wife without the chicks
what daughter so you know the name of
the video is Smuggler's blues oh yeah
great let me tell you something how was
the rule to be honest yeah we had a girl
another girl and her boyfriend uh-huh
then we had done like a halo thing and
those nights we were gonna quarter gram
of coke and just do a little blast and
we get together about 7:30 and we'd
watch TV till about 10:15 my 10:15 you
couldn't wait to get the [__] on there
to go [__] the second one to go
uh-huh yeah the drugs this video just
came on yeah yeah you're sitting there
going what the [__] is this [__] girl
music go ahead so what I was talking to
you I was thinking about this video and
let me tell how strong the video was
yeah you don't even see a band yeah man
oh you don't see a band in this vid keep
going up there's another one keep going
keep going keep going he gonna you know
man took it down these [__]
[__] it oh there's one right there
smugglers boys I think that the playlist
bastard
yeah ain't such a good [__]
I love that Eagle smugglers Blues Glenn
Frey coked up
that's the that's the description one
more time just to make sure yeah [__]
great sound you know those videos would
make you get up the next morning and run
to the [__] and MTV did it perfectly
you know was all of the part of the
[__] promotion yeah so everybody was
[__] in it so you got up the next day
and you were ready to [__] go
now scroll on that one scroll on that
one scrolls everything's right there on
the side I'm the [__] hey which one
all the way down boom there it is click
on that one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I can audio track with more oh wow
audio track removed bastard and that's
how it starts there in this when bullets
BAM yeah I hear the [__] guns getting
fired a lot it just grabbed you
yeah this had a be 84 when coke a was on
fire Oh Miami jeweled [__] everything
you know another Albin I would hate to
say it but you know what's a masterpiece
yeah
the long 100 I say always I'd it's to me
that record like a Hotel California of
course but to me it's the long run and
the long run along run from Greeks don't
window freaks oh the [__] in this city
in this city there's a bunch of [__] on
there oh the song along right you know
you can't find them shoes unfuckin I'm
[__] in YouTube really it took a
bunch of those down the heels let me
tell you something Joey I saw it last
week I'm just YouTube and like you and I
see this Eagles 76 turn to stone which
is a Joe Walsh song it's probably one of
the best live clips I've ever seen in my
life
76 Eagles turned to stone
don felder and joe walsh destroying the
guitars I can't even believe how good it
is
it's beyond like to me it's up there
with Zeppelin I was like look at this
[__] band in 76 they're killing
people you should check that out it is
unbelievable how crushing their you know
what I've I've always said this and I've
reached out to his people three times
yeah I love don felder love him as a
guitarist I love Don Felder he's a kiss
of death yep because nobody retouched
them nobody even called me yes he got
blackballed there's something for sure
something to happen yeah and here's a
guy that if anybody could play the
guitar it's that guy and he's underrated
as [__] he's like Joe Barry Joe Perry's
a lethal weapon
yeah and if you don't believe me you put
on [__] not either rocks or get your
wings get your wings yeah you know
there's so many albums that again we
just sit here and tell your prince
purple way but it's not yeah it's 1990
that to me it's sign of the times in my
top 10 it's a real top 10 100% it's a
double album it's all funk it's some of
the best songs he ever did I think it's
a masterpiece and it blows me away every
time I listen to it always I got it on
vinyl and it is the best record I think
he ever did you know what I'm gonna put
them on my list is fear you remind me
that's why I wanted again this with
y'all I do we Rudy Rudy was a
heavy-metal guy you would write for
everything yeah yeah so do you want to
do your toots at top like ten nine or
what do you want to do it how you gonna
do it I mean we're just going I think
it'd be cool of it like if you guys both
got to one at the same time oh yeah I'm
learning now you know with me I have a
lot a lot of different [__] I think that
uh I think highway the hell's a
masterpiece absolutely I think super
loans a masterpiece yeah I think either
Peach's a masterpiece yeah we were
talking about this band before we opened
up the show with this band Beatles I
think Abby
as a masterpiece but when it comes to
the Beatles they have three albums that
I think a real masterpiece
yeah one Abbey Road and the one with the
[__] waves on it when they really get
[__] crazy and then let it be yeah
and then let it be you know yeah so with
the Beatles you're always and if you
would ask me was 20 years ago I wouldn't
have told you let it be is on there
Beatles wouldn't it be 20 years ago
that's my point 20 years ago the Beatles
wouldn't have been in there for me at
all I'll be like that I'm not down with
that another realm that I always thought
was a masterpiece and it just meant
something to me was the pretenders 1 & 2
smoking I can't tell you I don't know if
it's a voice the guitars the energy this
times I hear that that those first two
albums and my [__] I can't believe
yeah so understand if I can underrated
that's just and you know like I said I
had a list that was longer than this oh
yeah I may tell putting things on there
you know again you go Joey where's the
heavy metal put out a lot of
masterpieces they did hey Dad you know
from for Pantera what's the one with
what's the one Pantera not the one would
piss on it oh you know indeed their own
vain if you listen to a noun you go they
will love to something yeah how they did
this
yeah high and dry by Def Leppard yeah I
had that on it I Romania yeah I take a
to [__] masterpiece
ya know why I had high and dry on there
how about this one for you Joey to me
and this is a clash London Calling not a
week ago I'm making a left turn onto one
of the streets close to hit and one of
those jams is on yeah
and I'm listening to it and I'm going
myself you know what I hate to say this
I really tried to life declare yeah yeah
I know
got over the iLab got it yeah never
fully got it yeah I liked that punk
scenes will extreme I just never got
that yeah that's fine that's why the
world is absolutely that's why and it
might hit you later on you know i-i-i
tweet every year on New Year's Day I'm
gonna try the who again every year gonna
try the who again you don't like Google
I like the food but I'm trying to get
into all the stuff I saw the WHO and 82
on the farewell tour blue might American
mine blew my [__] mind and the clash
open that show yes I saw them so you
know the who are always like fifth or
six to me when I'm throwing on some
classic rock you know it's like Zeppelin
and then it's the stones and then it's
the Beatles and then it's you know neo
young that kind of stuff and then it's
the who you know but I love the who I
respect everything about them but it's
not my go to you know but the clash
London Calling and give them enough rope
these records are so crazy to me because
they're like a punk rock band on their
first record but then they become like
skull reggae almost rockabilly punk all
this [__] on that one - calling it ghost
on this journey or like what the [__]
they're like all kinds of different
influences but it's the clash and the
just love their look their sound what
they stood for everything about it you
know it's just a crushing record but you
might want to check out give him enough
rope cuz that's a crazy cool record
because I had London going well I wasn't
crazy crazy crazy about alright and I
didn't get the whole hype behind and
then
you know you have to be maybe I don't I
don't know what it was and there's a lot
of bands II just don't understand
absolutely and when I was young I would
disagree with people as I got old I'm
like what the disagreement that's what
makes the world go round
yes everybody has their own [__] days
yeah and they break it down to you
sometimes somebody'll sell you something
there's a certain way that you'll give
it a try yeah most of the times people
try to sell you something you don't put
in the pot tell your wife throws away
your roommate takes and yes three
dollars at the record store yeah it's
the way people present it to me
yep listen to track track three and take
it from there
exactly I always say track that's what I
tell people all the time yeah when
people can I know when somebody's
selling me junk by the way they sell it
to me yeah take this a listen that it's
junk
yeah you know you have certain and then
listens everything yeah who gives me
some eventually it comes on in the car
I'll take three CDs and put them in and
eventually you know but yeah I like when
people have because that song has a
certain meaning to them which super no
for example yeah
fell on black days I was going through
that yeah as soon as I heard those
lyrics that the hairs on my neck stood
up I was the one I thought when I heard
I was like doing something in that small
rocky living room with the bench and the
TV and where I lived in Boulder and that
video was plenty and I just stopped and
I just knelt and said he's thinking
about what I'm going through right now
yeah I'm at war with these [__]
people I want to be a dad but guess what
I want to be a [__] comic to have an
in battle with myself and in my old
[__] prison
you know and it was like worse than
being in prison prison would have been
easier that time I was gonna throw
cheese's
so I really attached myself to that out
like that took that was the first time
super alone opened the door for my love
for Alice in Chains yeah and then I'm
gonna be honest with people hardware to
me
it was super unknown Alice in Chains
temple the dog
unbelievable then I got the Pearl Jam
right Pro Jam another one is that the
first one 10/10 yet another masterpiece
Oh what you want
Oh Joey it's a commercial album [__]
yeah put it on again listen to both
sides and send me a [__] email
[__] then I was still a [__]
masterpiece yeah 25 [__] years later
that that's the album that I always told
you that there was a lapse in my music
because I got the drugs of course I went
to prison like manic comedy I was trying
to learn [__] life we had enough time
to sit down like a [__] in the old
days that do or the grammar blow and
rock out headphones on yeah headphones
on and get paranoid and rock out the
[__] uh you know yeah whatever I
would listen to there was a period
I got a go from maybe I probably went
music blank and when I say music blank
to you is yeah that wherever I lived I
had like a cassette player and had four
cassettes
and that's what I would rotate yeah they
would be like the b-52s yeah a double
album in the old days you get to album
and is set to cassette someone about to
flip out that's the sign of the times
for me prance head yeah they flip ahead
I would always have way something by
Sabbath yeah and I'd have my shot day in
the Beatles yeah and I never listened to
anything outside like the radio in the
car never went on yeah you know my
roommate listened to talk radio which
made me despise all that [__] because he
would lay there like I'm lumpy love
cigarettes
yeah and argue with the radio about
sports oh you talk - you they're gonna
try to stand that I'm gonna train the
radio - oh my god color color for ya I
think you know if they just put it in
guys Richie one more time he would have
thrown long you know [__] you I would
listen to it alright
I used to love it argue with the radio
and when they call him then when he get
really drunk and coked up yeah he would
make the call
uh-huh and that and I'd be waking up to
[__] you [__] you did you hang up you
suck balls did you hang up yeah that
type of [__] I would wake up to that
so all that [__] so I got shut off from
music yeah maybe like an 86 that's how
it was with comedy right after Chris
Rock Seinfeld and Martin I think it's
maybe around mid 90s then I'm I'm out of
comedy completely until about 2000 you
know whenever Chappelle's Show comes on
and then I start hanging at the Laugh
Factory Jay Davis is doing that show but
I I don't know any comics from like
maybe 95 six to two thousand something
you know completely nothing I didn't
think about comedy nothing you know
there's three guys for me I was like
Chris Rock Seinfeld and Martin those are
the dudes and I'd go see him live every
time they can I was a comedy fan growing
up but let's face it I was a Richard
Pryor albums yeah yeah right
I lied out so we go live movie went out
I went to see it but I never in my
wildest dream ever thought of going to a
comedy club I would go see it and I
couldn't even breathe I saw Seinfeld and
Chris Rock at the Paramount Theater and
I stepped on that stage a couple years
ago the same spot okay and I looked at
the seat i sat it for Chris Rock I was
like I sitting right there man watching
him do these [__] joke and Here I am
right now and it's so bizarre bizarre I
know right it's really bizarre I love to
see comedy laughing stick oh man
no I would never because I want to do
coke and talk yeah yeah that's great
okay like I knew that from day one
well I do coke as oh and my friends and
me would you do coke and not talk to
each other we just looked but no no no
I always were the girl I was like a date
never never never thought about it I
never dreamt about it I thought like I
said I always thought that you would get
why feel friendly yours are looking up
scum in that taping tomorrow night at
this club some comedians are gonna be
there and a comedian would walk in do
his [__] time and he'll even write it
like he had done on the spot oh yeah I
always thought I always thought I
thought that for sure
so how that's how confused I was I
definitely thought that when I stand
then I started going the factory and I
was like these guys are doing the same
stuff all the time when I do comedy I'm
just gonna did new stuff every night oh
[__] it's funny I probably went to ten
concerts and hated the experience
because I didn't like the conversion of
the sound right right like the first
time I saw ever Smith I [__] cried
yeah I just bet it was a stadium yeah
and I expected to hear sonically get the
record yeah all the nuances I couldn't
uh I couldn't live with him I couldn't
handle yeah and it took me maybe five
years and I listened to the song remains
the same and then I got it and once I
got into comedy I really got towed I'm
really once you get the copy yeah oh
there right now I know but I also
remembered interview one of the best
interviews I ever heard I will rob a
plant on the that being will ever comedy
thing that that
they used to be a music show on Sunday
nights that was syndicated across the
country Oh like Tom effecti I better
just with your city wooden at the coffee
shop the guy that died a couple years
ago Bruce Coburn or whatever good luck
on no no no this guy had the King
Biscuit flower hour love that King
missing flowers the flower so I listened
to Robert Plant when that on it like I
was driving or something that was on and
it was very intriguing what he was
talking about he was talking about
listen we were doing the biggest venue
in the world at the time and then he
goes virtually it still is Madison
Square Garden yeah he goes if you rock a
place that's the place you have to blow
up like in our mind when we went in we
had a plan we were gonna blow up that
stage by Friday yeah
but we wanted then just a [__] burner
and by Friday you know he gave up a
really brilliance to me but he also goes
Jimmy Page was the best I ever saw him
on that five-day Ronnie
Wow by the third night he did things
that I can thought that you couldn't
humanly possibly do when I listen to his
words and the tone and I put the floor
mains the same back on and that's when I
realized how strong of a band they
really [__] work know yeah cuz I had
seen at that time I Drive to over 100
concerts Wow
and but I had never saw anything with
the impact that they had all like a wish
was to be there in 75 I know right if I
have any regrets is not being there in
75 as a 12 year old but it would have
killed me I would end up in prison at 14
yeah yeah a horrible experience somebody
was Ghostman acid you know I've seen
that concert of thousand times yeah yeah
and I've learned to appreciate that
sometimes you have to improvise but if
you improvise amrok you have to make it
a lot better when you improvising it's
[__]
yeah that's horrible then I think about
Aerosmith and I think about
they were just drugged out some people
can play on heroin and some can't but it
seemed like every time I saw now in
hindsight they were just a [__] mess
yeah and when I read the book I was like
Jesus Christ yeah right you know yeah
well [__] mess the concert was just
the thing they had to go do in the
middle of all their drugs it really was
yeah you know it really is a mess what
those guys got them like that like
Justin Bieber's crazy uh hello ever
spent on the 78 the 75 - you have no
[__] idea with ya see ya later man
I'll show you crazy you just whip up one
of their shows like dan the green and
look at them when I saw them at Monsters
of Rock and you just look at in there
like just stroke stone-cold junkies
stone-cold junkies up there just somehow
standing up in the wind and playing and
you're like how are they even alive you
know cuz you're touring you're not
sleeping you're just doing drugs and
booze how are you alive
it's crazy what your body can put up
with for a long time and then taps out
you know look at those guys still alive
right now crazy out living them all out
living them all and I mean you were in
that industry with like what
I can't imagine you guys go into a
comedy club strong on hit on heroin I
know and doing your dreads Hedberg Randy
made he did it for years but I to me I
love to be on stone-cold sober because
the feeling of it of like who I'm I'm
eating a dick right now oh I'm killing
or [__] this suck this side sucks over
here the backs good or whatever the
feelings I get from it are my high now
big time man as corny as that might
sound it's like [__] last night at a set
at the Laugh Factory where I was so
[__] high it was right up there with
any kind of drugs I did I stepped out I
don't even remember stepping off the
stage
I remember Fraser coming up going good
that kid and I was just floating off
like when that everything's working the
crowd work the material that
everything's all mix in perfect that
[__] is nuts man it's a little high it
is I still can't imagine like when I
think about and I think I talked about
this on Rogen I got a lot of heat like
those musicians who were on [__]
drugs
what's this a tional back that I'm in
the clapping was [__] up
great Richards was [__] up for a while
met Jagger was [__] up yeah you know
you read that I mean Nikki Sixx
jesus-fucking-christ think I [__]
took it to a different [__] level he
said you know what Belushi could suck my
dick yeah
that's basically what he said he was
Belushi was a [__] [__] there's a
rookie I'm smoking crack on a private
jet on the way to play a gig in front of
60,000 he's telling me you know that
they sell out the Oakland Coliseum on
the girls girls girls tour they're out
sad check no Nikki Sixx biggest show you
know in the States
where the [__] is he he's back home in
LA smoking crack
they fly this private jet to Van Nuys
they drive to his house kick down the
door grab him put him in the private jet
fly straight into Oakland he's there
about 8:30 smoking crack doing heroin
goes on plays a gig he doesn't even
remember and I tell him one of the best
shows I've ever seen he's I don't even
remember that gig I do remember them
picking me up and then I flew home on
the private jet Solo
all the guys were furious at me ha ha
[__] deadly heroin and crack smoke and
crack on the jet [__] radical 60,000
people girls girls girls tour that kind
of [__] is you know like I always say
drugs make great for a long time they
make great art and then either guy dies
or the crash and burn or they sober up
but why
there's a there's a quick little window
there where great [__] happens you know
yeah not necessarily but yeah it's tough
like like with all these these enablers
are crazy how can they go on tour like
like that's like that that's what I was
gonna get to is just like the people
that let them it's part survival the
glue that's that makes the machine roll
that makes the cash rolling yeah it's
all ninety four nights a week 18 [__]
week tour yeah sixteen fifty minimum
ticket at the door and the [__] math
Li it's a money making while steamroll
or up money you give them whatever it
takes to get on stage that [__]
tonight understand me I don't give a
[__] if you got a shotgun but
electricity and [__] nitrous oxide
pills out of hardened we got t-shirts to
sell you have an investment to make and
t-shirts to sell yeah if that's how they
choose to live their lives that's what
you you know you get to live to this
stuff which I you know Lee you gotta
imagine I'm um I'm [__] eleven twelve
I'm getting into music I'm smoking dope
once every three months and you would
smoke pot in those days at seven o'clock
at night you'd be [__] critically high
yeah you know nine thirty three four hat
so you went to blimpy base and got a
full-blown roast beef and cheese yeah
with everything chips and chocolate chip
cookie this was before the combo [__]
yeah killed it and then you put Visine
in your eyes you [__] rank Binaca out
and [__] walked home and prayed to
God your parents didn't see you and you
slept so [__] hard that night yeah
woke up with a weed hangover going I'll
never do that again
and I mean that's so I didn't understand
the whole concept of music Howard yeah
so music was some air life but it didn't
really bang me till I meant where music
met marijuana yeah
that's what sparked my [__] curiosity
and then their lifestyles like I still
remember plain as day Dean doll right
and if I have to remember names it would
take me an hour yep but I store them
being on 38th Street Court in North
Bergen New Jersey being 12 like in the
seventh grade maybe and listening to
these all the guys that were talking
about how listen man we're on the street
as Aerosmith is done that's what I heard
that's [__]
that's [__] they're all done they're
on heroine world island bump telling you
they're done bro then we're gonna break
up they're barely talked and I still
remember them bullshitting about it and
one guy that was not argumentative he
didn't say much a couple months later
walked up to those same guys on the
court and said hey did you get the new
Aerosmith down it was the one with the
diamonds oh yeah I'm never ever forgot
and it was a [__] masterpiece Oh
another yeah the structured masterpiece
in the middle of her not speaking now
when you get the book and then you see
what they were going through to put
together that out and if you've ever
been an addict if you close your eyes
and take yourself you go I don't know
how they did it Joe Perry Roo has signed
a list you had to sign yourself in to
the studio since Joe Perry and Tyler
didn't talk yeah they would have to be
in the studio to lay their tracks on
different times yeah yeah black Rostow
so they were going at one of Perry was
going at one you know he would he would
barely make it in there and one from the
heroin yeah he would lay his track then
they go right back to his room and ass
and locked himself in there shootout
would like it's fun yeah you can't even
you can't even imagine they're even
making me I said all I didn't let did
coke was hide yeah I couldn't even put
together a bongo solo
because I was too scared when I play the
bongos the cops would know where I was I
couldn't do anything musically nevermind
[__] heroin then you got a band that
came on 10 years later that they were
like my friend Steven Villa always says
my Creveling puss
they were Aerosmith on steroids a little
Plus Alice in Chains
yeah and they will [__] doing junk
love Bob on you up there let's see how
that Chinese [__] masterpiece records
last a piece [__] wreck all choked up
right a whole record about dope whole
record dirt you know angry chair [__]
all those songs are about dope you know
and and so here's a ban on dope writing
about dope and you're like wow this is
[__] [__] sorry when I heard that
[__] yeah but by that time I was still
in Boulder and I was blown the [__] away
like I had it and I kept saying Seattle
and I was always a fan of Seattle since
Lincoln they were they were the finals
with Jack Sikma
and they had one of my all-time favorite
players downtown Freddy Brown yeah so I
always thought I remember looking at the
map of it but the most important thing
was in the comedy magazine in the comedy
newspaper they had the coolest design of
a tower that dog would a clown on the
face yeah and I circled the night I
always wanted to go to Seattle so now
super known is that oh [__] [__] dirt
I don't know what do you dirt come on
I'm not sure maybe 92 and then the
three-legged dog comes right all right
yeah that records [__] which Ben is
there Allison out pretty sure it's 92 I
remember this guy gave me a cassette
tape buddy of mine he worked in the
studios hey guys check this out man 90
to 97 yeah by that by 95 I was hooked
line and second sorry to interrupt you
smarty but the guy gave me
egos hey I got the new Allison chance
and I loved him from man in the box face
left a record of course but he gives me
that wreck
it's like coming with his dirt yeah a
couple weeks before it comes out he's
all yeah check it out man he works in
the studio I put it on and I never took
it out of the cassette player in my
Toyota Tercel for the entire year that's
what I did the entire [__] year
that's what I did
unbelievable dad angry chair I had
rooster unknown van I got a the one
before Superunknown which i think is
also unqualified oh [__] yeah that one
was crisis three Jesus Christ Oh where'd
you find that I'm fine
they they just released it I'll get you
one how much did you pay oh [__] it was
only like 26 bucks that's not bad I'll
get it for you dude I was super I know
oh I'll get you that too they raised him
yeah wait can I find the money let me
tell you I got a couple cause I went to
my meeting
oh yeah well the music joins the guy
goes you know is to get those yeah he
goes it's gonna be tough but looking
online he told me yeah yeah I forgot all
about it now they re released him and
matter of fact I just got it and I put
it on record of the day on my Instagram
and people are going crazy like god this
thing sounds [__] great and it sounds
each one Jesus Christ posed the
Badmotorfinger finger to me it's the
record man like I always loved louder
than love forever I said it was my
favorite one forever but in the last
year so to me it's about Badmotorfinger
cuz Jesus Christ posed rusty cage you
know good eye closed oh no they got some
the one bulldozers in slave that is to
me a [__] his voice on that Jam takes
you into the murky waters of everyone
and stamping yeah I mean that album was
so like I said I'm not gonna lie nobody
and tell you I was definitely day one
yeah
loudly love Lauren yeah I discovered
them I know you're right I discovered
them through bad right here and then
super unknown yeah then it was put her
over the top put me over the top yeah
like I was like who the [__] are these
guys and then [__] I started
listening to Alice in Chains and then
Pearl Jam was a little too much for me
yeah but the girl but listen for this
yeah so I'm getting all these signs
I'm in [__] hell living in Boulder
I'm in hell I get I smacked John I got
arrested I'm watching the baby once a
week I'm struggling with comedy and I'm
getting all these signals from Seattle
right yeah hell I have [__] take a
weekend in Michigan I meet this stripper
and she tells me I'm getting my money
together I'm moving to Seattle why don't
you move with me and I'm like huh so all
my life last year Seattle's been all
over my [__] yeah SSI and this is a
sign come get me and she came to Boulder
and she went the Seattle first got an
apartment I moved in with her like a
month later I lived in Seattle 95 yeah
and you know she played pro gym every
day brother look like the singer Eddie
Vetter yeah and it was it was such a
great time because like I said I took
such a lapse from music between the
drugs yeah and everything but when I was
in prison I got tuned back up in 88
there now was fear of the black planet
hip hop and I was uh the dista albums
that were big in there were Bobby Brown
don't be cruel yeah don't be cruel Guns
& Roses Appetite for this horse yeah
when you walk by the bikers oh yeah
cake cake cake yeah
when you did that lethally is gonna like
to get it ha ha ha
laziness shocker a little bit leaves in
the home tonight yeah it's a Glee into
the murky water yeah where do you got 10
stars in I think so deep I got about 11
myself I got one more star for a lady
hearing yeah that's a good one you might
want to eat that one good I'm cool we
found a [__] petrified star I found
two of them ha and we gave them to our
friend yeah oh my god
cuz I one of the petrified stars a long
time yeah and I get it wrong you gotta
chew it yeah that's too much
yeah sure that it's like I said dicks
the next day though Oh a petrified stars
when it falls into the table yeah yeah
and it gets dust on it yeah I think it's
all the molecules yeah yeah just
Florence in fact hair dissolves the
dummy yeah so it's just pure THC when
you either oh [__] so it takes you a
while to chew it takes a while for that
mule to get in your bloodstream yeah but
when it does Dean they're busy you're a
different [__] planet Wow and then
one time I chopped it up and I put in
the bond yeah I'll smoke that we smoked
it we did we both did oh yeah
he's dedicate hi oh we was over there
mumbling humbling [__] oh I'm coming
back I'm gonna do the mushrooms you all
we're gonna do them all hell yeah
absolutely one of the hounds surprised
me or something else alright I'm gonna
because you're a doll listen you had a
potato yeah for years I ran it for the
most shallow is people when it came to
music and it asked me off
that's one quality I started pelvis to
write music yeah I like that type of
[__] oh this is classic rock it's
[__] you know what if you turn me
under the oil isn't on yeah from Miley
Cyrus the [__] sessions up in the
mountains
yeah I really can't I don't give a [__]
I don't either had a finalist no rules
with me I was at the Spanish music I got
like I tell you lately I've been
listening to the old Willy Cologne Elms
masterpiece is deemed our yeah the first
realm's a [__] masterpieces what hit
me will you let tell me okay here's
here's a record that has been in my life
my entire life and we used to live in
like when my mom got divorced
we're broke so we lived in this kind of
a kind of a weird two-story house and my
mom's best friend live there this chick
named Debbie I believe her name was she
later died and she had a Corvette 70s
Corvette she died in a drunk driving
crash but she moved in and my mom was
still kind of wild and she would have
these parties on Friday night and they
go from Friday to Sunday morning with
people like it was like I always said my
house early all was like that movie mask
you know say the bikers yes and Elliott
and all those guys would be at my house
you know the bar would unload in my Hut
and then they would be in there all
night now this record when it came on on
Sunday mornings at my house I knew that
everyone was passed out and it was gonna
be mellow and I could just [__] chill
finally and I love this record from that
day because of what it meant to me it
relaxed me it was Carole King's tapestry
yes yes
Carole King's tapestry when that came on
Sunday mornings at my house I knew that
they were all passing out the partiers
and I knew that it was going to be chill
and to this day when on Sundays I'll
throw it on and out of respect yep and
and just chill around my house and put
that thing on it's a goddamn masterpiece
was totally better you're slipping see
though that's the same reason I put on
that Tony bet it's unbelievable right
joy because I didn't open up the bar
with my mother that much yeah
when I did this is the first hole she
put on and then met the bar was open
right that's all huh
there's so there's records like that
rights is it this was there passed out
I'm a [__] seven eight year old and I
could walk around the house and I see
like the shrapnel just old boone's far
bottles Boone's Farm
that's that [__] wine it's from of
the ship cigarette ash tray fool you
know and guys with beards laying around
and chicks with long straight hair just
70s you know and that record you so
follow the way doesn't anybody you know
just come on I bet that's the [__] of
the mellow the mellow down easy and I
worship that record I've been trying to
get Carol King on my podcast for three
years
just [__] blows my mind what a
masterpiece that record is you know
about Carol Carol can't you two today
would that even understand does that
have it's too late baby yeah it's too
late twelve songs I grew up on that yeah
the other woman
yep okay yeah and there was one other
one not Joni Mitchell but there was one
of the woman that I grew up on I
listened to a lot anyway
that [__] is that it's got a few the
earth right that's got no that's so
[__] unbelievable and the you know
what I'm also from that era was good was
Paul Simon and [__] whatever awesome
uh I found one that me and Julio down by
the schoolyard the one of those am
bridge over troubled water yeah with the
boat on the cover right that was a good
[__] out well that era of those
singer songwriters like Cat Stevens that
[__] mad cat's in the cradle and assumes
you know those records are so [__]
good when you put them on you go wow
this songwriting is beyond and out
they're infallible like yeah that's that
music was so hard to follow some of
those out oh my god
and I don't know you try to figure out
what's missing what went wrong when you
listen to those out was it that they
don't put that much money into the
studio was it that they you know hey who
the [__] knows what we're gonna say Lee
he says I was one of the woman Barbara
Streisand that just any girl Barbra
servicetrace Navas
know he was Bob Australia was uh I just
watched her Netflix special I walked in
to the park oh yeah oh yeah she sang
this song about yeah did Dan dammit oh
yeah you're so vain yeah Carly Simon
Carly's [__] a dude and and everybody
wants to know who a the song was about
all these years it was about warm baby
yeah yeah and then you know stole their
thunder yeah
nobody remembers this a girl band they
were Rickie Lee Jones Nicky Lee Jones
yeah Chucky's our love yeah Chucky's a
man you went on Saturday my lively on a
Saturday night and just blew it
[__] [__] it smoking believe me it
took the money and hate cheeseburgers
yeah did she [__] disappear oh my god
but with in-n-out burger
oh just sad that the franchise hey see
if you find Chucky's in love live sound
that live or one of those yeah it was he
a sign I live or [__] Don Kirshner's she
did one of those yeah and that [__]
video that Monday I remember going back
to school yeah and that was it everybody
was Chucky [__] in love yeah Chucky's
in love with everybody everybody was
singing it it was everybody's [__]
song so girl everyone was holding [__]
hands to it ie or why at the end who the
[__] knows Chucky see see
all sudden the Spelling Bee champion ch
they would throw you with a [__] one
of those jaggies and that's how they
throw you off it gets ready for a big
word than you would Chucky yeah that's
how they do it you're waiting like did
you see what they did on [__]
Jeopardy last week oh did you watch
thanks Teresa gangster gangster supposed
to be gangsta yeah and they go they
given the points and then about two
minutes later they go
we're sorry bill our judges came in and
they said that you said gangster when
it's gangster I was cold-blooded a month
six-month probation so furious man
[__] jeopardy or whatever I've done
without the people [__] ours Trebek [__]
[__] Jeff Sessions [__] Alex Trebek
see what Chucky's our love how are you
pleased to Levesque right Chucky see
he's not even near the keyboard I'm
nearly Keeble area see ya Chucky Chuck
he's in love there it is
Chucky in love there it is let's find
the line 179 uh scroll down Lili I knew
it
let's see if we see the live one yeah
what's that
Oh teen yeah put it on there this is
this is how [__] a cheeseburger down
either cheeseburger cheeseburger
cheeseburger no oh she's having that
baby yeah yeah yeah but why would you
put a hat on to throw you off
why look at the hips when you look at
the Hat where's the sadly uh-huh sure
take a biker
[Music]
PMP with me oh my gosh down at the meet
video he's trying to do a weird version
but she was badass with this song oh
yeah this is if you went to see it and
they did this song for an hour yeah yeah
it was like a [__] kumbaya we click
it back to the regular video please
watch what she looked like in 19 schmuck
in 79 yeah I thought it was earlier yeah
may 10 to the 3rd yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
god they're not gonna [__] show us ah
this is just the songs yeah oh my god
I'm looking to that that Santana soul
sacrifice for Josh Cribbs
one of the best ever oh my god oh my god
Woodstock Santana I just got that on
vinyl they just released it you know
Rudy was talking about Santana that's
the best one it's not he gave me the
name yeah he said that they have like
the four time to fit down right dad
scroll it down buddy see what you get
no that's the honor to these
[__] yeah where's that old look
at Jackie then Jackie comes out haha
Blair is hysterical oh my god alright I
got another record that's gonna uh
here's another record I think is an
absolute masterpiece and I don't know if
you ever listen to it but it's by this
band you know Wilco
Wilco is like one of my favorite bands
hands down and they put out a record
called be in there and it's an absolute
masterpiece it's a double record and
it's by far one of my favorite records
ever I'm gonna leave for the video I
found it
let's see what this is nice oh yeah here
yeah she got the red beret
yeah
[Music]
so seven days all the band's back then
looked like this he had the sax player
[Applause]
the white-haired winder
[Music]
yeah this is big this is big about mr.
Shindo away that massive bag and [__]
depressed yeah this is big oh man this
is less to live with my mother and a
house she's probably still torn on that
term if she's alive still you know no
you know what yeah we just saw that yes
without some Elms after that you know it
should just listen that there's a lot of
people just resumed their bottle yeah
yeah I'll put that out oh yeah they kept
that core fanbase I love for the studios
or the record companies to believe that
they could break even a little scenario
they do a little tour which again you
don't hear about yeah you know and you
just look at all these bands that are
coming back yeah they're [__] and
half the bands are named and even people
said that to me all the term they go hey
what happened to the wallflower psycho
man they got like seven records out
they've been touring since that big one
and the [__] records are phenomenal
I mean phenomenal Bruce Springsteen just
named his ten favorite songwriters in
the last 20 years and he said Jacob
Dylan was number two for this record he
did I think it's called women women in
love or so I forget the name of it but
he named it number two Bruce Springsteen
man it's like you know people are out
there working and people just drop off
it's like with the Black Crowes people
always ask me whatever happened to them
after their first record I'm like oh
they put out like five masterpieces
after that you know what happened to you
you know why did you drop off it's so
weird you know when I was really really
into music I was on it you know how she
is yep before I realized that life came
in life was more important than yeah you
know yes it's gonna go on sale next
Thursday yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that's all you lived about well
that that was your biggest worry
what was what was only one sale next
[__] Thursday I never I never forgot
to be Tuesday they would come out I'd be
at that Tower Records and that guy would
have an odd way hooky I would go rad to
school like three o'clock I go straight
down there
no line and sometimes if it was [__]
something coming out you know like
you're not the waiting line like waiting
by the time you got there you go what do
you got yeah and then go around we got
these seats here but 225 bucks I don't
think you want those what do you think
boss can you spring the extra five hours
it's on the way there you have like a
budget yeah I'm telling you man I can
only go 20 if I have to I guess still
gotta get home and I won't buy quite a
movie from Nicky Barnes yeah yeah yeah I
listen come on give us the tickets cuz
they would negotiate yeah what you went
to that window that's what they have we
have 25 aisle seats
we got $15 seats and we got $3 seats
yeah that's it take your pick knowing
all right I'll take the 15 and sneak
down it's actually you would do [__] yes
just go where's the $25 seats yeah and
they'd show them to you what seats were
open and you'd pick the ones that you
thought they wouldn't sell yeah and then
you said all right give me the $15 seats
close to that seat so you could just
throw be overweight now after the third
song oh yeah
you just swivel your way over there like
done some of the security got cut a
third song you know what I do is every
time right when the lights drop and the
people are going crazy for the band
right when they're walking on the lights
drop they got the intro soon as that
happens I'm gone ended on they don't
even know to get you turn on this fire
always like gone there I am in the front
every [__] time on the rail my shirts
all had black lines on them from being
on the rail all night you know just wood
rail just pressed up [__] up ribs
front row can do oh man another one
would sentimental reason yeah but you
listen to it today I always put it on
the plane yeah I don't try to listen to
it when it's around on a plane I listen
to it and it's entirely every [__]
song I like there's some mountains that
that's what's wrong because I know you
think the car is underrated I feel the
same way
oh my god first two hours I
I loved them I really did I love hats 84
I don't know I'm not responsible for him
yeah but those first two elves I think I
got him in the bin they will [__]
phenomenally I even go later cars
because I love that song drive who's
gonna tie like that who that was 84 also
on that side bruiser don't mix it in
nuts disappear cruiser crouppen or sings
this song called cruiser it's one of the
best car songs ever cruiser i [__]
love it I met Ric Ocasek in New York
about two months ago and it floored me
in a [__] deli across the street from
the stand comedy club I'm in there
getting a [__] protein bar I go
that's Ric Ocasek and the guy working
there goes yeah man he's here every day
I holy [__] I gotta get a photo him I
went up I said dude I saw you on the
shake it up tour at the Cow Palace you
had no pissed tracks he goes what's a
piss track I go you had no songs that I
could go piss to because they were all
[__] hits and he started laughing
again spits tracks and he was cool he
took a picture with me and I was like
[__] in heaven and they just got in
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame last two
weeks ago
[__] great finally after their fourth
try I'm like are you kidding me
look at these songs go to the greatest
hits right now on iTunes the greatest
hits
it's got 15 hits and they're not in the
Hall of Fame first round [__] you it's
crazy I gotta tell you something I think
the first down was very good also ah
very vote for a flirt you know you gotta
remember again another hound that I
thought was a masterpiece and the way
they put it together Zeppelin - oh god
yeah that's just me I always thought on
the allianz Zeppelin - was the one that
spoke to me you know we could sit here
and tell you it's the war what was a
great album but to me it's a [__] tie
between wish you were here and animals
you're so right
you're so right and I lean towards wish
you were here believing that yeah I
think I kind of burned myself out on
animals and risa I'm back
I wish your here that Shinedown crazy
dynamic comes on it's been money it's
just a it's just it takes you on this
[__] this ride man
you uh you sit down this is the Pink
Floyd and you feel bad about yourself
about being a comic and how unprepared
you are when you listen to them right
because they're to the [__] note and
they have everything planned
you know then [__] albums with three
songs yeah it's crazy you know and the
three songs bang that out 250 [__]
minutes and that was it and you listen
to every minute god forbid you drop the
mushroom or hit acid no Mike put the
mine they sucked you in there's some
headphones once they sucked you in Pink
Floyd Pink Floyd sucked me in two of the
best acid trips I had it was Pink Floyd
uh dark silent moon when time sucked me
uh-huh yeah and one time animals took me
into a dark [__] place yeah by the
time they got finished in me I was like
a chicken coop oh man I thought I had
animals around me I kept thinking how to
get up the feet the goats I didn't know
where the food was uh it was [__]
crazy oh I took Friday night off and I
didn't have any spots at the hut and I
just put on wish you were here and you
know I got these speakers and all the
sounds were coming out I got the final
on you know I'm just going like this
[__] thing man I can't even believe
it you know it's crazy how good that
band is it's insane it really isn't it
isn't sad that's like four or five dudes
you know and it sounds like nine hundred
dudes you know I got a throw
synchronicity in there yeah I gotta
throw the b-52s first time I got Devo
b-52s first down the second side could
be one of those sides which is
questionable yeah depending upon your
taste but I still like that that first
side yes enough to [__] put it up
there like it's if you pay the five
bucks for it now is that the one with
rock lobster yeah yeah the right way it
leads up to
it leads up to rock lobster [__]
brilliantly yeah let me get some shout
out yes and we'll get this party started
how you feelin Lee I feel great
apex killers okey spooky holding it down
and [__]
keeping the count on the door at Austin
whoa down there from the 18th to the
20th Chris lochness this tecnique MMA ex
minor farce
one two three four after life I type
Burgas and my main man who I'll see next
month in Denver be in Colorado him
saying
and don't forget cap city the 18th to
the 20th and my man Dean Dell Rizzi
the 19th and the 20th ya nineteen twenty
twenty-one lawyer taping his [__] CD
of debt come on Atlas other things like
I said Nikki Sixx's it'll be down there
yeah slash from Guns and Roses will be
the audience James Lee Roth David Lee
Roth's if you got everyone come on down
bring it I'll be there waiting on you
you know I'm saying can't wait to do
this now you tape the CD already I did I
taped it at Denver Comedy Works people
keep going where is that it sounds a
little weird you said it's just too big
actually the it was like the show was so
good that I was like bigger than I would
be I bet yeah because the crowd was so
wild that I was wild and there's really
kind of no dynamics to it it's just like
a punch in the face the whole time where
I wanted to be a little more like I am
live you know it's just so hopped up you
know those crowds were incredible some
of those shows were sold out that
weekend and it was just [__] fire and
I saw I listened to it it sounds amazing
and it's great but it's it's it's not
doesn't have dynamics I like a comedy
record that takes you on a journey takes
you down up down you know I mean I just
want to and then the jokes got way
better the jokes got way better so I'm
gonna try it in your never happier will
you put on paper once you look at it
all right to close it out your top three
I think McCarthy Allen's I mean beside
the Beatles that we've discussed no band
on the run I mean David Bowie put out
some great music yeah no you know yeah
we both met you Fleetwood Mac whether
it's rulers a Stevie Nicks first or
second solo album yeah yeah good Tom
Petty had a couple great out wildfires
wildflowers yeah well for masterpiece I
had it in my best I gotta be honest with
you as much as I'm not a fan we gotta
put one to run up there that's my number
one there you go
that's mine everyone think of the same
thing some I never I'm not gonna city
with you and argue really body yeah I'm
a big Springsteen fan I'm just telling
you that I'm until recently now recently
about five years ago I always had a copy
that out oh yeah some reason I got
hooked on that home in 1979 that things
I've never let it go never and my
favorite is Tenth Avenue freezer
unbelievable to satirize me that was the
whole song that I got locked in III God
just I didn't put him up there's number
one yeah but I always try to give
respect to somebody I really thought
about deep purple I really thought about
you know I had Van Halen - yeah warning
in there uh yeah fair warning there was
a time in my life where I played that
record straight
and those tour that tour blew my mind oh
it did for me also yeah and that first
side is a killer it's insane I don't
know for sure I went to see a concert
and I think it's rainbow and the
scorpions in 82 right was that the tour
yes stone cold breakout was named in the
blackout blackout alright but I saw the
scorpions once before
Katherine you look through Jersey and I
can't remember with who
unbelievable band I think that another
album I like the patois which way I
like the patois of animal magnetism
unbelievable
I also like the patois lovedrive know of
a UFO out alive oh my god they have with
the one that lights out no no no no no
no they have one out that I always
thought then when you listen to it you
go okay but you know what let me listen
to it again and then the more you listen
to it the more you go whoa that song is
fire but this song the song that always
reminded me of it the big song on the
album is one more for the rodeo right my
UFO that's the big song on the album
I always start that album blended
perfectly those are those sounds that
you listen to
even before comedy and I can tell the
preparation yeah as I listen to it I can
tell what they were doing I can feel it
even though I didn't know I could just
feel them putting together another album
that I really enjoyed Steely Dan Asia
oh it's insane Steely Dan agent get out
just kinda but I grew up on that I
really enjoy them yeah that's why it's
always very rough yeah to say what your
favorite all-time [__] hours are and
then you like but Joey yeah you're a
[__] Sabbath guy you have not
mentioned Saboteur singing I always say
that it's there those are the obvious I
gotta tell you with them if you're a
true fan you like all of them but if I
had a single not my favorite Sabbath
album and it's tough yeah
cuz it's closed between paranoid it's
closed between master reality vol 4
Jesus Christ
that's my album Sabbath bloody Sabbath
my album but the one that destroyed me
till this day sabotage yeah yeah right
that's my favorite [__] out and I got
200 more favorite out from me too I'm up
there here's my Metallica like people
my god italica to me when you go and
justice for all justice for all
yeah and people go masters yeah masters
was a one a now that's on unjustice for
object then you go but masters to me was
of course it's everybody's go to
Metallica record but to me justice for
all all of a sudden they just they
played a type of metal known was playing
it was prog metal is these long weird
songs that were just insane man I was
like what is this you know and it's just
a total journey and it to me it's
injustice for all yeah every time you
click whoa he jumps up in the air missed
a few people the podcast tonight huh to
play open the door yeah I had a little
tiny piece of mushroom yeah and I felt
that go through my system so [__] bad
really that small piece at these
mushrooms whoa or something
that's why they're [__] super unknown
that's what's crazy too because I'm
telling you you had a for Joey Diaz this
piece was like something you found on
the for session on these mushrooms do
not [__] oh I'm done I'm okay now Wow
for about 30 minutes I went through how
it was like when you spoke oh really
I had to get up open the window oh man
actually we just to see if I have an
anxiety pill which I knew I didn't yeah
I had to reach in and get a water what
little piece that little piece and I
haven booked it I booked a mushroom
twice Oh burp a little piece like that
it's sitting down [__] throw yeah
it's sitting down like I said they are
not I hate to get me read nibbles did
you your piece I'm gonna to say if
you're looking on the video it was about
this big it was a throwing on inch not
even not even not even not even more
than a quarter of an inch and the other
I had
three of those and I left here went home
in The Exorcist was on oh my god the
[__] cat kept looking at the clock
and it just [__] me up oh my god is a
tremendous I can't imagine if you ain't
like a gram or something I gave them to
a friend of mine he doesn't let me tell
you what they were
oh yeah he goes through a type of
mushroom but if I can grab that because
I don't have that happen because they
take you for [__] ride whoa he goes
is like two hours there it was good but
he doesn't then went away and I was fine
Wow I saw Woodley the of it that we was
high for a while did you take some yeah
I didn't you didn't tell me all this
before I took one so how are they live
for you oh you know what do we get we
[__] win happy that we were heavy
that night so I thought it was just
really high no I haven't like I haven't
done mushroom wood to that extent yet
like I've done acid before right hello
allegedly I was here we needed acid um
maybe yeah maybe oh absolutely they told
that if you ever test himself with a
drug test
yeah he's like I'm back it shot the
thing would break oh he's got heroin
this is yeah
the mad at the old place in heroin yeah
yeah I can't believe those mushrooms are
that strong yeah this room have easy
mushrooms you got any more left
maybe yeah baby they caused by the with
that booty oh my god oh my god in the
car hey what dates do you have see your
tape love the CD okay that's like I said
like I told you people Wow and I repeat
the again on every podcast the reason
why this kids apopka here on the podcast
it's cuz I love the more number two the
reason why I love them because it's a
non-stop awesome who [__] gets on a
plane yeah to go do [__] spots for 35
bucks
my man here because he's not in it for
the [__] money
he knows the longevity of it he knows if
he takes a beating now and in in other
words eat a dick yeah then in three
years this will he'll laugh at all this
I've been eating so Derek's eight years
yeah
it's Ted asleep on somebody's for you
look at the [__] rich Cohen yeah yeah
if you got a chance to support Dean even
Timmy went to see a bunch of my friend
I did yeah you having me on a bunch of
shows last year not only helping me out
with their shows but the fun times we've
had man you know you bought that picture
in New York oh yeah all my other people
that we were down the base yeah yeah
having a talk with my ages yeah and next
thing you know you ran down to tell me
what okay
I'm up there taking pictures just
hanging out and all sudden I hear what
you say [__] two girls pulling each
other's hair and a guy throws a table at
the fight throws a table at the fight
now two dudes are going at it the whole
place breaks into a right the whole
[__] got Gotham comedy club
I mean bull brawl some broke up noses
and bloodied up foreheads weight guy
threw a table
the fights yeah he threw a table at the
fight like break it up and that's how he
said break it up with a table and it
just went and and no none of the people
in there wanted to go in it was like
radical did he hit them with the table
[__] yeah man people went down guy came
out all buddy and oh man it was a fierce
it was absolutely awesome and it was on
Instagram for a while somebody filmed it
all that sound be tweeted that was the
best show I went to yeah it was a great
fight after the show great comedy show
great fight guy got them said been here
24 years never seen a fight in here ever
oh my god it was crazy
god damn but that but my point is some
of those nights we've had were just
unbelievable Perea I remember punch line
recently punch I'm available it's a
punch line you know you guys come on
support and it's a great feeling that
we're all everybody's up for the same
sense of humor now nobody comes and
doesn't know what to get themselves into
right yeah it's fans the comedies are
the beautiful [__] high right now and
you know you can't [__] him tonight yeah
oh I was gonna say check my podcast out
on Monday tomorrow I have a great guest
John 5 the guitar player for Rob Zombie
and this [__] guy had some killer or
stories man he's played with David Lee
Roth he played with Marilyn Manson he
played with Rob Halford he's played with
Tori Amos and now he's been a Rob Zombie
for since Oh 5 and check it out let
there be talk incredible guest man I
listen to the show today editing it and
I was like wow this episode it's crazy
well he's like one of those high guns
why he was on hired gun
okay they go yeah but now he's a Rob's
up yeah he's been there for years and
you know he's got a kiss room at his
house a whole room is kiss my
memorabilia from 73 to 82 all kiss
memorabilia the pinball machine the doll
sticker
records you know Oh everything they ever
did photos posters unbelievable I would
talk about anything on the doors as far
as albums absolutely man
the first doors record which just was
released like last week was the
anniversary of it and that [__] record
is just insane you know guess what I was
listening to a couple days ago and I
listened to it for about 40 minutes
while I was working a American prayer oh
I love that one
oh that everybody forgets about that oh
that thing's great it's a little creepy
yeah when you fell ill advised a Furby
it's a little the creepy side right you
really don't know you know it like to
light that out you have to listen to
three doors out yeah and really like it
yeah like the end yeah you got like a
lot of his dark stuff Kenny what isn't
that one the one with ten credits to
kill his mom yeah yeah and yeah the end
that's crazy
ma I want to kill you [__] yeah [__]
yeah that what song would scare Lee the
headphones off Lee uh he always plays
doesn't scary I know I know that time
from the famous video that that's out
there and Leon on Mars or whatever we're
playing like we're playing these don't
bring it up just salt on Jesus oh my
awake what why rip that [__] scab oh
sorry I just love that Casey you're
scared of the video that we had on I was
like Iron Maiden like number of the
beast you saw in the video was the mob
the Beast you're like oh I remember I
looked over you
was another video well was it something
deep purple deep purple purple uh space
truck and it's no no no those are the
dirt - what were they in the video where
they all go to the house and reunite
with the all they have like that perfect
strangers we have perfect strangers
[__] what's his days playing the
drums that was the funniest every time
yeah it's amazing at the symbol Oh wake
up and look at him [__] god damn thing
about Eva's in college and what they
promised them what happened to the
placement program you can see it yeah we
would put his head back and breathe oh
yeah he would go through that for every
thriller yeah what happened to that
counselor from lemon I love both the
cats why did he [__] tell me the
truth
uh-huh look at where I'm in I'm in a
[__] office yeah hi [__] hi ice
fog
I got no [__] life got a green shirt
on today [__] [__] yeah tinkers hi
last night you know you drank this joy
this [__] is unbelievable boat Chico
what is it just water with a Flintwood
oh yeah just a natural lemon no sugar no
sugar and I was in awe snow sugar
[__] sugar [__] sugar now let me
talk to you people about something here
all right because this is what it's all
about sometimes right now you're sitting
there going you know what I don't know
what to do with what I got
well let's pretend you want to turn a
cool idea into a new website you either
want to showcase your work you want to
plug or publish content you want to sell
products and services of all kinds or
you want to promote your physical or
online business let me tell you
something beautiful templates created by
world-class designers squarespace.com
is the way to go why they have analytics
that help you grow in real time they got
a built-in search engine optimization
and they got free and secure hosting and
nothing to patch or upgrade ever 24/7
award-winning customer support making
itself easily create a website by
yourself make it stand out and stand out
with a beautiful website okay ready to
start your new business make it stand
out
it started with sweat with Squarespace
think it dream it and make it with
Squarespace all right
Destiny's calling it says you need a new
website make it with Squarespace the
future is coming
make it brighter with Squarespace keep
dreaming but make it a reality with a
website from a Squarespace okay now it's
this simple what I want you to do is
check out square pay Squarespace calm
for a free trial when you're ready to
launch use the offer code Church to save
10% on your first purchase of a website
or a domain that squarespace.com and the
code Church CH you are CH listen
powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online the
ability to customize look and feel
settings and products and more with this
just a few clicks a new way to buy
domains and the choose from over 200
extensions do me a favor
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial when you're ready to rock the
house when you're ready to go you use
the offer code Church and you save 10%
off your first purchase of website or
domain that squarespace.com entered
church okay that's number one number two
I'm going without a doctor coz Islands
there for me from the day one when I get
up in the morning the hemp for its
protein the cocoa the cacao is delicious
and if I'm running out I switch
governments and I go to the outside even
Ella why because that's how I roll two
scoops some water and a few ice cubes I
take my little blood pressure medication
and tip top mangu I bong it and I'm
ready for [__] Godzilla you want to
be ready for Godzilla
go to Hahnenkamm right now look through
the supplements okay I cannot help you
with the kettlebells or the bachelors
like that as far as supplements I got
your back get that out for brain it's a
30-day money-back guarantee if you don't
like it and you don't even have to send
it back
get [__] hemp force protein to try
but for sure with the flu season going
rapid if I was you I'd be going on it
calm right now forget that [__]
shroom take a meal okay so if you sit
next to a Japanese guy with the mask
[__] him [__] him
you got [__] shroom tech immune you
don't want him breathing on you all
right gonna calm and press in church BAM
and there you go ten percent right off
the Vig from uncle Joey again I want to
thank squarespace.com and I want to
thank alikom but most importantly my
personal music entrepreneur my brother
mr. Dean Delray now thanks Arnie you're
off with you I'm sure I'll get some
dates and we'll be working together
I can't wait dad my brothers Lee oh I
wanted to say something good I built my
new website with Squarespace there you
go Dean Del Ray was it I can't even
believe how great it is man it's so easy
thing everybody [__] loves it
everybody got these great templates you
just pick one you just drop photos in my
tour dates it when I put the tour dates
in it updates them and puts it's [__]
great man I'm gonna try squarespace comm
code Church and get 10% off your first
purchase all right Lee I love you
[__] nothin there is your guys if
it was the deans Del Ray let there be
rock let to be talk let them be talk
rock you know me I'm all [__] up yeah
take it from there Lisa yeah you bad
mother [__] and by the way lawyers worth
the drive guys from LA it's really fun
it's beautiful so go spend the dango see
Dean it's great thank you from the guy
who goes to [__]
you understand one [__] travel advice
from it should be the first guy yes you
know I am buying five [__] hours on
New Year's Day that's fun it was fun
oh [__]
speak of the devil yeah yeah it's the
mother [__] doors [__] one of my
favorite [__] out great vdl a woman
what a great [__] hours for seeing the
video he's driving the Mustang I love
our Gray's we gotta pull it all together
it's so great this guy was unbelievable
unbelievable five to one that's on five
to one when you listen to him it took me
a while that poetry [__] yeah I didn't
buy it broke I hated him growing out hey
I didn't like the organ and then one day
it [__] click yeah I just [__]
Robbie Krieger
guitar playing unbelievable I'll take
you into the deep waters like a [__]
shark dog and you don't even see it
coming this way he just turns it up on
it yeah total Spanish style you know
he's just like flamenco style it's great
this this [__] record right here is
unbelievable this record
[Music]
we're a little girl
bang